hello everybody and welcome once again
to insensitivity training on court
McGowan I'm Joe bartnik and we are
officially in the brand-new all things
comedy studios want to thank everybody
who got on to start and donated and
built this is nice man yeah it's like
smells clean it smells clean it's
different than mine that smells a little
bit like old smoke and dogs and in feet
Oh your apartments much more comfortable
your your apartment like the the puss
the stories just come out of the couch
the smell is disgusting but we have a
special guest today another all things
comedy a guy a comedian as well and and
a good friend in a racquetball player
ladies and gentlemen all the way from
Toronto Canada mr. Harlan Williams hey
buddy
hey buddy how are ya I'm doing a great
racquetball [ __ ] yeah yeah well me in
court play all the time well he plays I
kind of get my ass whipped
well that's not necessarily true I mean
sir Lord is the king of everything's
1978 it's done in 1978 I'm still good at
hacky sack I can throw a frisbee yeah
in golf I can do that that was a no
that's a good sport you have a pet rock
still probably yeah it's probably a
boulder by now so a stone it's oh wow
Wow no I kept around SARS oh yeah but
it's it's great to be in here man I mean
this is like this is this is kind of
cool yeah I like what they did I never
do I like the LG they went real high-end
on the video behind us there's no video
today thanks Mike and Aaron I took a
shower and well I hopped in my pool you
hopped in your pool yeah you just moved
you got a new guy guys I'm still
swimming in my old place okay
Wow rough life to walk in between pools
Wow
yeah well when you're paying right in
both places I feel like I'm obligated to
do something at the other one
yeah you should at least go back and
like just take a dump and go and then go
right in the pool after about well of
course without this insensitivity
this is insensitive and really all my
senses are being assaulted all right you
guys have never met interesting about
the two you guys that you'll have a lot
in common in is Toronto you play you
still play you play roller hockey right
you jockey now you play this is the
hockey king right here Joe is an alt I
mean watching watching hockey please but
knows every Munoz knows everything about
hockey has hockey podcast and love to
have you on sometime oh goody I got some
good hockey story well yeah I'm sure you
do what do you think well I now of
course I mean not be mad but we could
talk hockey now for an hour but what do
you think about Brandi Carlile getting
the ax
oh the Toronto coach right yeah well he
wasn't there very long which is they
don't last long in Toronto yeah and I
heard that you know they were doing
pretty good this year I think they what
loss was good they were one point in a
playoff but Boston just won last night's
another one point I have a playoff
but basically you know that's always the
same thing every every year it's like
well who can get castle to play defense
and it wasn't Randi Carlos now they have
two interim guys they're basically
saving up money to try to buy you know
Babcock from Detroit that's what they're
gonna do oh yeah yeah Wow boy Toronto
needs to win it's been 50 years so this
year's year seven you know wow that is a
long especially being Canadian yeah
that's a long time now isn't the Hockey
Hall of Fame in Toronto yeah yeah it's
amazing if you if you got lucky all the
fame I haven't been to the new one I
went to the old one oh the new one yeah
like a church and I don't like churches
but it's it's awesome it's a good yeah
it's right the downstairs is like very
like kid-friendly and you can like take
a slap shot against Brodeur and then
they have Gretzky and them you come down
try and I did all that I was
they they have the real Canadians locker
room from like rocket Rashard and then
upstairs is just you know how like in
Canton they have the bus yeah yeah in
Toronto they just have like really
beautifully drawn pictures with like
with like just like a paragraph about
the guy all everywhere and then you
could go into like this fortress because
it used to be an old bank and then
inside the fortress is like the original
Stanley Cup Oh like the original like
like all the oldest mice and all the
yeah yeah I think the Ark of the
Covenant though like this sunlight
shines into the it sounds like Raiders
of the Lost Cup yes pathetic Zack is
really awesome especially if you like
hockey and if I go back to Toronto
anyway yeah I gotta check that our South
that's amazing yeah I got a update
that's like me out of the 70s I was in
the Hockey Hall of Fame of the 70s did
you even you were were you just knee
high to just a little bit just to squirt
a little bit yeah a little squirt and
you're in there just like just resting
your chin on the cop and having a good
time and yeah just you know you guys are
badasses though you guys both ride
motorcycles and you play racquetball let
me take some racquetball is undeniably
one of the most dangerous sports when I
was like five or six my mom played
racquetball it was like two guys and two
girls in a court which fit you know like
it easy to have an orgy than actually
play racquetball and this dude hit this
woman in the back of the head what's the
racket and it was like ambulances and it
was like after that like it in my
next-door neighbor like broke his face
one time and like that's where my dad
was like you'd be a fool to play
racquetball
it's crazy it's one of those sports
you're in this little bitty in this
little bitty thing with hard walls
there's no give yeah it's not like no I
can hockey when you hit the glass it
gives a little if people are swinging
racket yeah but somebody asked us the
other day they go do you guys you guys
want to play us in doubles we're like no
that's too many [ __ ] people in the
court oh yeah that's four that's four
two too many
yeah but there's enough but I mean I
have any hit you really hard
I've hit you a couple times
but not hard hard well we have a rule we
have a rule that if them if it gets too
close you just stop the play because
we're not we're not playing for a you
know a gold medal so if if the ball gets
near another guy's head and you're
swinging you just stop yeah so we had a
safety mechanism but there is that thing
where he does like to kind of move he's
a good play good enough player he likes
to move into the center of the court in
front of you when the ball goes back and
I don't have any real problem like if
he's gonna stand in the middle and I
want to go there he might take one in
the back you know he just leaves the
game right you're athletic and you're
obviously the best looking man in
podcasting thank you but but Heartland
actually has like you know he has some
shoulders like it'd be tough to get
around him in a parlous like he's an
athletic dude too is bigger than you
barley hits the ball arlynn hits the
ball hard he acts like he doesn't but he
hits the ball hard he's a good player
and and I I do win more than I lose but
I also I'm one of these people that I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm giving it 110
percent the entire time and if I can
beating by 15 instead of 13 I want to be
by 15 13 where is in Harlan stopped like
oh I'm gonna hit court in the head I'll
give him that PO I'm like I like look at
it go is it close enough to his head
yeah I can swing I just swing yeah yeah
but but no we enjoy it we've we've known
each other a long time I used to come
out and do it do the Vegas show swooner
you're one of the first people who were
like one of the bigger names that came
out when I started the palms yeah we had
some fun yeah we have some doesn't start
at the palms it started at the palms one
of my favorite memories ever at the
Palms was the day that your cousin is in
the band
Barenaked Ladies yeah so his cousins
backstage with us in another comic
another friend Sean tweed Lee is on
stage and we just looked at each other
the three of us and we go let's just
strip down to our underwear and walk
across the back of the stage while Sean
was up on stage performing and he wasn't
having he wasn't eating [ __ ] but he
wasn't having the most
raucous set ever they were listening
they were listening and all of a sudden
this crowd just starts going well but we
did all three of us just went from the
backstage we walked out in her underwear
the three of us is nothing but our
underwear and socks on walked out walked
right across the stage and out off the
stage and through another door and went
around back around the back and also in
the crowd just starts kind of going wild
and he's kind of like you know kind of
proud of himself until he looks out of
the corners I and sees three guys in her
underwear [ __ ] go by yes we won't we
walk behind them yeah without the United
No yeah it's kind of fun yeah I need
maybe you had to be easy last night at
in sand where the Venice oh yeah did you
do the Venice underground yeah it was
fun I think I had a fun set
what's the Venice underground it's a
cool it's a cool night where they do it
it's right down on the right off the
boardwalk so it's a it's a mix of like
outside is a mix of homeless people and
heroin addicts and then inside you go
downstairs in this really old it's a
very old bar and it's very cool and it
holds a they get they get a hundred and
like fifty people in there and for free
and it's great and they and they love
the shows oh it's like it's like it's
amazing it's always an amazing show it
looks a little like a bordello
downstairs well then after us we had
burlesque yeah and it was funny and I
wanted to steak is a chicken nice dance
but I forgot my wallet and I was like I
don't need to get pulled over like I'd
rather just have like no you know my
breath oh yeah please I don't have a
wallet and you know that sort of thing
yeah it might feel like they're my
lights are out on my truck from Kenny
Wayne Shepherd house yeah when he backed
into a tree the lights went out well the
one light is eschewed you hit a tree
yeah yeah I've given a lot to this
podcast it was a rainy day in a tree one
that would get out of the way very quick
I'm not crazy
yeah I'm not quick yeah I'm hard to move
once I get in front of the net but I'm
not quick not quick that's right you
don't do the butterfly well but you do
it well that's what happens when people
write into even
playing comedy basketball people bump
into me and they're like Jesus oh my
goood I'm not going anywhere I said geez
you're I'm solid dude like Joseph solid
guy I doubt that - yeah it's like dude
I'm not going out you know you can hit
me you know I'll help you find your
board
I don't movements yeah yeah
it's interesting because when you think
about it of all the people like you want
to [ __ ] around with especially like now
you see like these bouncers and clubs
and bouncers and clubs now are not
necessarily the most the guy that's like
you know built like he works out or
anything it's a guy that's so solid that
like he just moves through the crowd
everything goes out of the way you can't
move the guy and then you can a guy can
just wail on him and it really doesn't
feel it and he just like absent by the
scruff of the neck and takes him out
which is what you used to do look at my
nose that's what used to be a bouncer
yeah I used to do it I used to do about
bouncing did you ever have any like did
you ever have at a time when you were
bouncing where there was like one of
those instances where [ __ ] broke out
where you go this is gonna this is this
is ugly it's gonna get really ugly uh
yeah a bunch of times
did you really well I worked right next
to the I was I when I was a kid I worked
my first real bouncing job was I was in
charge of the bouncers an underage
bartender at the Clark bar Grill in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania yeah which is
right next to Three Rivers Stadium
oh sure which we would have like six
bouncers and like a couple off-duty city
cops and there was a war it was every
night was like the NWO right I'm just
crazy
it really had like three rules like
don't touch a waitress if a waitress
once you're gone you're gone if a
bartender what you're gone you're gone
you're gone and like don't rip [ __ ] off
the wall and would still end up tossing
a bunch of people but I mean it was you
know but you know is what it is what's
the rule with bouncers out front like
from a litigation point of view are our
bouncers legally allowed to hit people
or I haven't done it I haven't bounced
in like 20 years
but what so what's the legal law like
that's what I'm saying back when I did
it yeah in Pittsburgh the legal law was
you know the cops are all your buddies
and you give them Jack and cokes and you
can kill it killed everyone nowadays
with cell phones and mine you know and
like women cops and I don't know what
the real you know I don't you know this
is Pittsburgh in the late 80s early
night you know so there's no actual law
that gives bounces the authority to use
physical force like under the protection
of the law I think it you have to get
hit first and then I would think so
that's a way to always but I mean like I
used to train the train about I used to
be in charge but I'm always like we're
always the nicest guys and this is when
I was big my nickname was Indian Joe I
was twice as big as I Cukor's now I was
twice as big as I am now maybe not
weight wise but you know muscle and I
was always like just be nice to
everybody cuz people are happy when the
bouncers nice and everyone's cool and it
made it that you do something then it's
like then it's your ass if you're always
just sitting on the stool hanging out
then it's like there's never a problem
because they don't know what's gonna
happen to them and I always kind of
worked in some joints and had some
reputations work people didn't really
want to find out what would happen to
you yeah easier to punch a guy artist
throw a guy my move is always instantly
grab a guy by the neck and I was strong
enough to pick most people up by the
neck cuz we have it when you have a guy
by the neck in there against the wall
they usually like I'll listen to you
yeah yes I would have to say that would
make me [ __ ] listen
somebody has you because yeah that's
like the thing like have you ever been
punched in the neck
that hurts yeah that hurts the force is
stronger this woman did Darth Vader do
that in the first I remember he picked
one of his cronies up by the neck yeah
Aaron Aaron up in the air you're asking
the wrong dude about Star Wars yeah I
never I think I've seen it but it's been
a long time it's been a while that's why
we have guys we're highness scenes it
the Star Wars guys working the crew yeah
right right you know what I'm talking
about player we've got a Star Wars
player so now you now let's talk about
let's talk about some of your movie
career
you do have some of my favorite the
all-time favorite you don't want to talk
about when I bounced yeah when you
bounce I bounce to the Chuckie Cheese
and Chuckie Cheese in the bouncy house
out the ball kids or kids are a lot
easier to pick up by the throat by the
way like four years old and younger just
you can pick them up you can even put a
finger under their Jeep in their
[ __ ] ones yeah yeah even them they
kick a little more but when you're
saying get out yeah that's their heads
are heavier
oh sweet Christmas crumble cake when you
wake up in Nelly Furtado's fleshy arms
oh Jesus is that a man or a woman
even though you've you ever done for
tato yati I've never done a Nelly
Furtado you've never had sex with her
and now I have not have you she must not
live in the Western center in her inner
fleshy arm you take my silences whatever
you want I'm not answering so let's talk
about you are you scared - the real
Nelly yeah who's Nelly the real Nelly
yeah rapper dude let's go here
Nelly the guy with the golden tooth and
abandoned well that's that's a pretty
broad answer to that guy that's a broad
speculating for the same roles that's
true funny guy tough guy hilarious yeah
okay Wow Natalie well this is the only
wrong turn no why I was just joking I'm
saying I actually think Nelly has like
the greatest video ever
what's one the each one's his hip drill
the uncut remember that lava lava the
ETI cut was the greatest two hours of
television ever yeah you had to get your
work done because right after it was
over then the Reverend would come on no
way yeah exactly like the Reverend on
there was like a like a real-life that's
on Sunday like it was always like
midnight to 4:00 a.m. would be like the
etn cut of just like the most the
greatest black hot ass videos ever but
then right it'd be like Nellie like I
need it real boom it literally be like
whatever a priest like but a reverend
dude yeah yeah literally like instantly
it wasn't even like a commercial and
then the Reverend and now that you now
that you've beat off to all this hot ass
we're going to shame you
to death sitting there with the dirty
cell I was sitting there with a dirty
sock on your chest he comes on it goes
on now Jesus and you feel really bad
because he's black he's kind of like
real like he's a real minister yeah as
opposed like a white guy begging just
getting money begging he's really like
feeling the Lord do they have that in
Canada growing up do you guys have the
the know I know I know you don't have
God but I mean but do you have do you
have like the evangelists
like because when I was growing up that
was like you know you had Billy Graham
you had all the guys yeah yeah we'd get
all the feed from the state oh did you
evangelist you know we'd have like the
Ernest Angley Oh Ernest was my favorite
man cuz he didn't Ernest Angley had the
thing where especially like I think it
was like in the late 70s early 80s when
they just finally figured out that
cigarette smoking was bad he would have
people come up and they were sicker and
he would and he would go up to and he
put his hand on their forehead he'd go
out nicotine devil and they would all
fall back ah ah
then they would remember that yeah devil
get out definitely like push their
forehead pushed her forehead and they'd
fall back and if my favorite was out the
nicotine devil and they'd have a little
seizure a full-on tremble I would really
I'd like to have just go on that one
time and like have a guy do that and go
all [ __ ] yeah you know just like
stand up and go [ __ ] you know there's
still guys doing that I saw one recently
on TV I forget where I was but there was
a guy walking through the crowd touching
people and people people with want you
know one leg I all of a sudden grew a
new one like Swamp Thing no [ __ ] way
people were like getting up out of
wheelchairs and blind people were like
you know doing Rubik's cubes all of us
it was ridiculous like this guy was
doing more miracles than God himself
it was unreal see that's the weird thing
and the craziest part about it all is
everyone that's there in the 4 million
people that are watching this you buy
every buy into it and they all start
sending in money because those guys are
making millions of dollars a
a people need something we need a
preacher in the studio whatever out the
nikah to send your money portrait now in
your mind
sensitivity training calm said your
pledges it works it works
woo well you're as you were bored in the
Bible Belt I mean that's obviously
epitome I had I had a babysitter when I
was growing like you know your mom you
know your mom always like you have one
like babysitter that your mom hires like
all the time because she's the only one
that can keep you in check yeah like I
had two brothers there was three boys it
took a [ __ ] powerful woman babysitter
to keep us from [ __ ] burning [ __ ]
down and and we had this lady named mrs.
Harville swear to god that was her name
and she wore her hair in a bun and I
mean like always in a bun never saw it
not out of a bun and it was like I mean
it was wound tight this [ __ ] thing
was oh and she's like the kind of woman
that like had didn't have you know I had
like nine kids she took care of it was
like the woman that cleaned your ears
with a bobby pin
like I mean it was like she's just like
you whatever she knew how to do
everything
yeah and she used to take us keep a man
except yeah and let's she was not like
photogenic let's just I didn't think she
was out and and she most people are
photogenic find easier ways to make
money than raising someone else's three
kids
yeah hours of the time exactly and but
she used to have a [ __ ] tight grip
and she's oh I wish but no but she used
to take us to her church which my mom
wouldn't my parents didn't ever went to
church but they send us with with her we
went to this thing called the Church of
Christ in Oklahoma and let me tell you
something this is some [ __ ] racist
[ __ ] bigoted [ __ ] homophobic [ __ ]
that goes on in these churches
I mean racist all racist dude I mean not
I mean not like out and out like you
know but yeah a little racist man a
little a little [ __ ] weird it's a
little [ __ ] weird you go in there
what they need everybody's money no
that's white yellow green
I know I don't know there's not a
there's not a maybe today there is the
back this was in the 70s in the
seventies and yeah we'd go in there and
the whole thing was like they sang the
hymns the whole night and they would
smack you like they had no problem like
you you you know in church you know they
sit there and they just you did
something wrong they just [ __ ] smack
you right in the back of the head or you
know smack your hand or whatever it you
know you had will they smack you with
their hand Wow
you know maybe they're just trying to
get the tobacco devil out if they
nicotine down yeah out the nicotine
right all mooing in that church right ah
people are probably chewing tobacco in
that church I don't know but it was
[ __ ] weird man that was some weird
[ __ ] I feel like we have Harlan here we
should talk to work with all that suck
more with Harlan what I want to talk
about because you're you have you have
probably what you have like one of those
movies that have the real quotable
quotes and I think that's a cool thing
to have if you're if you're in a movie
and you have I mean obviously one of the
one of the most famous ones is from
Something About Mary
and that's the 6-minute at is it
six-minute abs six-minute abs minute abs
and and it's like one of those things
where it's like it's really funny
because when you look at it like if you
always go six-minute abs six-minute abs
and everyone [ __ ] knows what you're
talking about do you get that a lot deep
yeah yeah people you know the movies
movies like stood the test of time with
that people people just remember all
those lines and quote them to me people
remember them better than I do to be
honest so yeah it's it's it's robots
it's real nice that you know it had an
effect on people you know cuz you got to
do
probably the to two of the Farrelly
Brothers biggest hits Dumb and Dumber
and and something about me yeah those
are two of their probably their biggest
they're my favorite movies regardless
that that I'm in them it like out of
their movies they're my top two favorite
well I think when you look at Dumb and
Dumber like you never would have
expected Jeff Daniels to be as [ __ ]
good as he was
yeah as as [ __ ] you know in Dumb and
Dumber yeah I was like probably I mean
cuz you look at him now
he's in like newsroom and I saw Dumb and
Dumber - which was just an absolute
piece of [ __ ] you know it was just such
a bad sound but one one I mean what is
that's what that's what it's all about
yeah great yeah I mean I agree with you
like I was probably that's right the
fair one was that your first roll the up
first movie first movie ever yeah come
out of the gate with Dumb and Dumber
yeah and then when did you do the one
with Chappelle half-baked half-baked
half-baked we did is that after
something about Mary
no no half-baked was before Something
About Mary and how did you hook up with
Chappelle was it just happened you guys
happen to hook up audition I mean did
you meet before did you guys knew each
other before yeah Dave and I worked a
whole lotta around Hollywood at that at
the comedy clubs we were both we're both
kind of working at nights and the
Hollywood clubs like doing guest sets
all over the place so we'd see each
other a lot and then when half-baked
came up I didn't know anything about it
but Dave and in Paramount Studios like
they they wanted me for it so they asked
me to do it and I think I turned it down
like four or five times I didn't want to
do it because it was a drug movie right
and I I was a little conflicted about
you know doing something that you know
kind of promoted drug use in a way and
you know not to promote it but I don't
know I was I was concerned about doing a
movie about drugs okay and uh and so I
passed on it and then finally they just
kept coming at me and I kind of started
thinking you know it's just another role
and I'm an actor I'm not but so I was a
little conflicted but I finally ended up
doing it I was happy about it I'd say
cuz that's a cult classic
yeah it was fun I mean it's one of those
another one of those things that's like
you look at and it's like I think I
don't think you could say Dumb and
Dumber is a cult classic it's just a
it's just a big hit movie and I think
Something About Mary
kind of borders that cult classic and
and blockbuster because Something About
Mary is kind of a weird I mean the
Farrelly Brothers are [ __ ] weird yeah
yeah well the
funniest guy in that movie to me is Matt
Dillon when you go back and watch a
movie again like now that he's kind of
faded a bit from the acting scene it's
like if you watch what he does in that
movie he's just totally or yes he was my
favorite part of the movie I actually
walked out of that movie did you yeah
more after my part I saw you I used to
give free movie tickets from being a
comic in San Francisco so I walked out
at more movies but I just the very end I
never saw Favre like I never saw you
never saw them ever saw the fog the far
apart but uh but uh yeah I just think
it's great that I think you have the
career that I think everyone wants in
the fact you're just in a couple great
movies and yeah yeah you know and that's
what you want you want to be able to say
like you know and you know it's like
what Bowie and so yeah I was in
half-baked and dumb and Dumberer and
some of them were like oh you know it's
not like thirty movies they're like yeah
you like it or not one like one-hit
wonder like you're like three [ __ ]
boom you know I think it's great I
wouldn't cute I remember when I first
started comedy I when I'm very first
like I was still I like my fin like to
open mics and like first one week worked
at the punchline as a door guy I met I
met I I met I forget his first thing
I've really might know but you know mr.
Pete's a man he's a stand-up comic
forever i from from fans where's my high
hotel or negro yeah oh wow and this was
30 years later than that and I'm just
like this guy's still a headliner I know
he's done other stuff but you know he's
still ahead later on like he was the his
pizza guy you know boom I'm like that's
it you've done a million things in your
ear completely you're a machine
you don't mean that's all you really
need is like unlike the billboard of any
comic club he was in dumb and dumber and
half-baked like okay you know it's an
amazing thing oh yeah and I wish someone
would let me do it
oh I know I don't say that you just you
just undermined yourself people know oh
no I don't believe it for one Nelly
Furtado second but if you but you look
at you go back to looking and I mean I'm
looking I just kind of looked through
some of the stuff you've done in I mean
I'd you know we I know a lot of things
you've done but I mean it's like you got
like the whole nine yards you've got to
work with some pretty cool people Bruce
Willis you know Matthew Perry's a funny
dude you got to work with Patricia
Arquette you got you got a [ __ ] from
Patricia Arquette or not a was a
Patricia Arquette not Patricia man one
right Roseanna Roseanna yeah yeah you
got him with the overbite yeah yeah you
got oh wow yeah how'd that work out well
it was a movie blow just so it wasn't
real barley I know you could have Matt
you were imagining though right you're a
method actor so you actually said you've
got to put it in your mouth for this to
really work for me
how many girls with big overbite did you
go through just to uh just to practice
oh man I should looking back I should
have you guys you guys are right about
this and then you also when you also go
back because you've also gotten a chance
to star in your own movies like you know
Rocket Man yeah and Rocket Man was like
one of those and now that's another one
because we work the road together so I
it's inevitably someone always brings
the Rocket Man poster or they bring the
Rocket Man DVD and there was I you got
to sign the you know in it and that's
another one of those it kind of became
the cult classic movie yeah and how is
it that you are so do you consider
yourself now a cult classic God and I
never thought about it buddy but but III
think I'd just say yeah I've been in
some really classic cool movies and
rocket man's interesting because um you
know when Disney released it they kind
of market it more towards kids and
families even though I think it could
have played at any level because I kind
of you know geared the humor towards
more of the Ace Ventura the college
crowd but but tons of kids watched it
and now now there's all those kids are
like 20 to 23 years old and now I've got
this whole resurgent
of Rocket Man fans coming to my live
stand-up show so it's pretty darn cool
it's got to be fun any wave and then you
you know you do a lot also do animation
you Robot Chicken you do a lot you've
done some of the other stuff yeah you
kind of like chicken your are you behind
that I I was I wrote on it for all my
god that voice I did that is absolutely
one of the absolute funniest things
every other so we had a lot of fun yeah
as a good time and I bet it well but I
blew me away know that yeah how did you
guys pushed every envelope on that [ __ ]
was pretty pretty odd you it was fun to
do yeah yeah what's the process of that
with like do you write it and then they
animate it or like I mean I've you know
yeah you you write at first and then
they then they animate it they think
claymation
how long does it take him to claim a
know that's that stuffs a long process
but the skits were yeah as you know
pretty short right their longest skits
were like maybe two and a half minutes
was a little considered a long one and I
think every now and then they did like a
four-minute one but they were really
really so so and it's the studio we
would write upstairs in a writers room
like about this size for those of you
listening like you know forty feet by 40
feet or 30 feet by 30 feet whatever the
dimensions are nearing meters by 18
meters mattering for the Europeans yeah
there you go
and yeah you know it's tough to I get
confused cuz I'm used to gallons and you
know inches and I was up in Canada and I
went to a 7-eleven and I bought by
accident about 22 kilometers of milk and
I walked one day I talked I clocked it
out I walked three million 250 thousand
millimeters to the mall and that's just
that warming out have where ya at that
corner mine that's millions yeah isn't
it funny the only thing we've taken is
the 2 liter yeah just coke taken that's
all you need really
they're actually there I remember when
they were actually trying to convert
that and it never never it was like [ __ ]
off we're not doing well the reason they
do it they say the metric system is more
precise it's it's fractionally a little
bit closer to perfect and that's the
whole reason for it that the
measurements are closer to perfection
then well the math is easier and I I'm
no good at math but I mean is it the
math it's all ones and zeroes it's not
like I guess that's why it's easier for
fractions I guess I guess but I don't
like it I see I got I was one of those
kids that got scorched in the middle I
grew up in Canada we started on the
gallons and the inches and the pounds
and then when I was in about grade six
the government said well we're gonna
switch over to the metric system kids
and you know I just got the gallons and
the pounds and the inches in my head and
then I kind of had this rebellious thing
like I ain't changed man I'm happy where
I am so hey changing I barely figured
out metrics man I gone down metrics
street player but going back to the
animation stuff oh yes so one question
that's kind of I wanted to say and I
didn't spit out quickly the first first
time was how much rewriting do you do or
once the clays in there cuz I know
Simpsons are
self-park they kind of change it up at
the very end if they have to yeah my
animations tough once you've won a meet
you once you've locked it in it's tough
to move stuff around it's a little
easier now with the digital era we live
in but it's it's never easy and it's
costly so you never really had like a
run they could test it and see if it
worked and if it didn't you go back and
they just whatever you wrote they did
well no the guys for the writers hand it
off to the storyboard guys and then the
storyboard artists and the animators
kind of you know futz around with with
the posing and the direction and and
this you know the the whole scene and
you'll be amazed how much comedy and
whatever animated movie you watch rather
it's a DreamWorks or a Disney thing a
lot of a lot of the comedy and action
and stuff like that gets created by
storyboard artists and and directors and
stuff so the the writings interpretive
to a degree
there's jokes written on the page
but animators can really make a scene
and the humor pop just on how they model
and and and draw everything out and
position it don't you think that's like
the big new advance and animation like I
I mean I have a kid i watch boomerang
all the time nice like hanna-barbera
stuff but it's all pretty much flat in I
mean I it's great animation but I mean
and now it's like the animation is just
so sophisticated in a way yeah you know
what I mean it's like Doc McStuffins and
stuff yeah where it's just like it's
like it kind of blows your mind compared
to the old stuff yeah yeah it's it's
incredible
I mean just look at avatar you know yeah
that was a form of you know digital
animation with a lot of that stuff in
there the lot of the effects a lot of
the creatures a lot of the backgrounds
it's daunting I don't I don't know your
whole cat have you ever acted against
animation how do you mean like like
against a green screen where you we're
actually doing something and the
character is not there so it's done in
green screen I'm gonna be like if
scooby-doo or whatever have you ever I
did an episode of scooby-doo I think
what you mean is is like that stuff you
mean when you put the sensors on your
body and act in front of a green screen
type of thing or just no I mean just
like if you ever been in a movie where
there's like one of the characters is
like is animated it's not there
you don't mean oh yeah I did I did a
Disney movie where I I had to do a bunch
of that stuff in front of a green screen
and it wasn't with another character but
it was it was with a bunch of objects
and and inanimate objects and birds and
things like that you think that they're
pretend you have to fake all that yeah
yeah so is that it's weird it's weird
because you're you're conjuring it all
up in your head you know and so you you
you kind of have to visualize it so you
have a point to look and yet it's it's
very strange it's like acting in a
vacuum right and that that kind of leads
into what I was gonna say next was is
that you have this mind of like I don't
know how to describe it other than if
they haven't seen you to stand up it's
it's it's [ __ ] fun because you are
you are very animated
person and you and I and I don't know is
there a way that is it just come from
the way you did commie or the way you
you that what makes you funny because to
hang out with you we have some you know
I mean for others I'll tell you a great
stories we went to a party one time
Arlen and I and Tom Green we're all
together and we go to this party and the
whole night we we basically played these
characters and it's like it's ourselves
but Harlan walks and he goes yeah we're
opening an Olive Garden down on La
Cienega and Melrose next month is going
to be opening up next month courts gonna
be running the night manager and and we
just kind of did this this thing all
night it's like and you just kind of
think in this weird and I'm not and I
don't mean weird bad I mean nerd fun
yeah you think in a weird way that I
don't know how to [ __ ] describe it
unless you're there and you experience
it it's [ __ ] strange because you know
like all night long he's going around
going out you know talk to court about
the breadsticks and completely serious
you know like I mean I know you're
joking but you were completely I mean we
had literally people googling all of
Garland La Cienega and Melrose
we had people texting us going well we
can we come in Thursday you know like we
sold it yeah but Wednesday night is all
night breadstick yeah Wednesday nights
all night breadsticks you think about
ones yeah think about whiskey and talk
to court because he runs the president
manager courts banging chicks who he's a
given a waitressing job yeah but is it
like it's interesting but do you like is
that just where does that come in if you
don't mind me where does that come from
that you you kind of do live and you
don't live in it but I mean but you kind
of love to create this world of fantasy
that like I think one time we were the
like my dad invented jelly and your dad
invented peanut butter and that's how we
met yeah you know like you you create
these great scenarios and you kind of
live these scenarios through a night is
that just like a weird like not and I
don't mean weird bad I mean no I hear ya
it you know it's it's a perpetual search
for means to entertain myself is that
what it is yeah yeah I I don't write for
whatever reason as much as I love comedy
and and all kinds of entertainment I
sometimes give bored
that quickly because it's it's like I
need stuff that's like totally kind of
twisted and obscured yeah to really get
me giggling like yeah I'll laugh at
everything else but to really get me
giggling I like kind of stuff that's off
the wall more than anything else so I
think it just comes from trying to amuse
myself and when I can draw their people
into it it amuses me out even more I was
in Vegas once with with our boy Sean
Tweed Lee yeah and we are up in the
ghost bar up on the you know it's just a
hundred degrees and everyone's out and
you know people were recognizing me and
I'd see people lock eyes with me from
across the bar you know groups of people
on it and wave them over I'd be like
come here come here I'm waving I'm so
animated and and they're doing that
thing where they pointed themselves like
what me you want me to I'm like yeah
bring everyone over I'm yelling I got
some great news come over so like four
or five people six seven people at a
time we come running over like Oh guys I
got some great news I can't wait to tell
you and they're like what what is it my
god you see this guy here and I'd point
it my friend Sean tweedily they go yeah
yeah right now I've got them all whipped
up into a fur I go this guy works at
Baskin Robbins and he just got promoted
to milkshake maker they'd be like what
what you just to see their faces drop I
mean that's the kind of like that's the
kind of fun like kind of like fun stuff
that like when you're in the middle of
it with you you're like ah what the [ __ ]
is going on like how do you like you're
telling people I make breads on the
breadstick guy and the night manager
night and it's like and that's that what
it is it's just you need that like you
need that kind of just makes me laugh
and if I'm at a party or something get
bored I'm I'm not a real Boozer I'm not
a partier
so my my kind of fuel to have a good
time is to just get silly and goofy and
kind of start fabricating this world of
madness where where nothing really makes
sense but you draw people into it and
suck them into this weird reality where
they're not sure what's real
or makes me laugh would love to see how
dumb the people are who thought that
your dad was George Washington Carver
that's perfect everyone knows like I
mean even I know that George Washington
Carver invented peanut butter well I I
know but that this was like Harlan's one
of the whitest people I know
ya know well we we actually the other
thing we did is we were at in Vegas on a
top night club was called fusion or some
crazy and we were at a party and I got
everyone gathered up and I was bringing
them all over and introducing them to
you and saying this guy's father this is
this is court Baskins and I'm Edie
Robins
his father's our fathers and men in
baskin-robbins like just ridiculous
stuff and it's weird and it's in it in
it but it's weird like because you don't
know what the [ __ ] he's gonna say like
what Harlan's gonna come up with so
you're just kind of sitting there and he
kind of comes up with a em right now
yeah yeah yeah you're like on what the
hell is going on I don't even I don't
get it I don't know and now where does
that where does that get just boredom
just sheer boredom not maybe not boredom
but there's a little bit of boredom of
the I also like to push people's buttons
that are be unaware and you see how they
react if you ever push people and they
went the other way well not really
because they died I kind of do it so
convincingly that they can't refute it
or dispute it like that they're kind of
just confused right because it collage
eclis it could have happened like I was
with a guy one night and I convinced
everyone who came around that he won't
appeal it surprised because he you know
when you open a can of Pringles yeah
it's got to be standing up right well
this guy would lay them down and take
the Pringles out sideways and he won a
Pulitzer Prize and people were just what
I'm confused already I know but you know
he VIN stem that if you he kind of came
up his mind was so deep that he could
lay the
Pringles down sideways and extract the
chips versus having it standing upright
and taking out chips I convinced people
that one girl told me to [ __ ] off yeah
yeah it's an intense deep thing
Pringles laying sideways okay maybe I
smoked too much weed video for today for
this yeah
where's Mike so now when you like does
that help with you because now you've
created your own animation series you've
got your own animation series you're
gonna be doing yeah and is that help you
create does that help because animation
I think is like one of those things
where like you know like so you watch a
lot of animation with your daughter you
watch them and by myself and by your
okay but do you find it really are some
it's great my kid loves Family Guy yeah
family and it's so great because my
daughter's 10 so it's like she's really
getting a wicked sense of humor now well
cuz that's it's got a certain sense do
you think you can go like cuz Family Guy
goes way further because it's animated
that anybody could you couldn't do that
on a show you couldn't say half the
things you're saying that part goes way
everything on television goes way more
that isn't some guy right i know i mean
i think animated do you find that that's
like pretty much the case well yeah it's
great cuz that that plays into you you
know you can deep as your imagination
can go that's what you can do with
animation there there is no limit you
know so it's that's the beauty of it I
love it I love it it's just until I get
Slyke we talk about the new animated
show yeah I can't yet you can't yeah I
cannot talk about it yet but I wouldn't
involve Pringles no it does not involve
pretty mind-blowing is sideways Pringles
yeah it's a Pulitzer Prize winning show
I think you should have a guy on there
that has a peel it surprised because he
opened the can of Pringles sideways and
you should show it on there and it's
hard people can't swallow it it's very
intense for pits were think otherwise
actually it really really Ilyas to open
take your chips out sideways on the
table now you've been a member of the
all thing
Comedy Network for a long time you're
one first you're one of the very first
guys that came on the tide bill when
they don't know and and when you first
came out you you've had a I guess I want
to say you when you started out with a
radio show you know cuz you were kind of
at the beginning of podcasting yeah so
it's interesting everyone thinks of I
mean I think a lot of people think of
Marc Maron as kind of the father and and
Carolla is kind of the fathers of
podcasting in a certain I'm not trying
to psych up the bill but I I think Bill
is the first guy that was like I mean
Corolla got kicked off a radio or
whatever happened right and Bill had his
for but I think bill was first I was in
al magicals I was at the Christmas party
when L told Marin you should just do a
podcast in your basement oh wow oh
really
yeah I think bill was already up and
running
yeah but it but you started you had a
show that used to do called the Harlan
Highway which is still the name of your
podcast yeah but you used to do that for
a radio station in Colorado is that yeah
I did I did the drive home show in
Denver for a year and from your house
though from your house from your house
in Laurel Canyon yeah that's right so
you would record it you would do it live
or you would do no I would I would pre
record it and then it was amazing
because I would just you know send in
the the segments right and then they
would they would air them every night
and I did it for a year
and then the contract ended and then and
then that was it for for a year and a
half or so I just went silent and then
some somehow I or some way I saw this
podcasting thing happening by a couple
of people and I thought man that's right
in my wheelhouse because I've already
done radio and I really liked the medium
and and I've got a bunch of segments
that I all the bits I did on the radio
show I owned so I was able to yeah I was
able to inject those into a podcast like
little little sketches and stuff and so
that made up part of the podcast and and
so I thought I'll try podcasting so I
was I was probably in the stand-up
comedy world in this in the States maybe
in Canada too I was I think I was kind
of one of the earlier guys maybe the
first five or ten to kind of get into it
so my podcast the Harlan Highway is
still up and running to this day I think
I'm in my six year or something yeah
yeah cuz it seems like yeah it seems
like you bill and I think there was and
I think Corolla only did it because he
was kicked off I mean once he lost his
radio gig but he made but his thing that
was awesome was he made it where people
then realized that people are podcasting
right you know it was like it was a big
deal that it was like oh what's he gonna
do well I'm gonna podcast people like oh
what's that
and then yeah a nice platform but I
think it's interesting that you're in
Laurel Canyon and it's like you know
it's a blizzard in Denver and you're
like how's the traffic do you ever
pretend like oh it's a hell of a time
getting to work today though no and I
think that was probably why the gig only
lasted a year because you know it was it
was a little bit tough to get a feel of
the community not being there and I
think they wanted out a weird community
they're very they're very into Denver
because they're so isolated up there on
the mountain yeah so the fact that I
kind of didn't have that hands-on touch
I think even though we did really well
we we brought the ratings up to number
two and we did really well but but at
the end of the day we ended we only did
one year so but but it was kind of the
catalyst for me to jump into podcasting
because I was already kind of revved up
and go man I like that kind of yeah in
the end nothing like having a bunch of
bits all ready to roll already and the
equipment - they hooked me up to do in
my house so I was like I was I was like
primed to go and and it's something I
always wanted to do my first my first
album when I was in stand-up comedy it
was like in the 80s I did a cassette I
was one of the few guys that sold
merchandise I got into that real early -
and and I did a cassette that was
basically was called when rhubarb turns
to radish it was basically it was a
spoof of radio it was my wacky
interpretation of a radio station and
and that's exactly what I'm doing now
all these years later so I was kind of
had I had an outlet to podcast in the
80s
probably would have started right then
but it didn't exist so it's a full
circle and is it do you think that you
think podcasting is I mean it's now it
seems like there's just so much out
there and so much content out there
what's chain twitch changed from when
you started to where you are now is
anything changed with your podcast
anything like you have you found it
harder because I mean obviously it's
difficult yeah difficult now you know we
have absolutely the best podcast in the
world and it's difficult to find it's
difficult to build these massive
audiences but like you have like Rogan
or you have fir and you have these ones
in there there's there's the top ones
and I think everything else just kind of
falls a little not necessarily not
saying that any of them are bad because
I think most podcasts are good because
it's someone's opinion yeah they're all
valid yeah you know I I don't think you
can look at any podcast and say that's
that's awful because it's their opinion
yeah I'm being very nice today well you
know basically podcasting is in general
it's killing time
you know it's what people do when
they're in the Stairmaster it's when I I
listen in the car when I'm driving like
I you know it's like it's something so
if we can remotely entertain anybody and
hopefully we're entertaining people then
that's all it's it's all it's about you
know it doesn't I mean you know I think
the I thought the bar is low but I mean
I think it's like it's just you know you
just have to be I don't know can you
speak to this without I don't dig dig
dig a bigger hole no no I think really
what's happened is is it's become an
easy medium for for guys you know with
zero budget a guy with a guy with no
money in his pocket could basically you
know for a hundred bucks rig up a
podcast set up right and go from
obscurity to sending his voice out
globally which is was just quite a
spectrum to encompass and so I think I
think what's happened is a lot of people
have jumped in like everybody who has a
stand-up comedy set pretty much has a
podcast now and and why not
you know everyone should have a chance
to do what they want to do but in that
process it's watered everything down a
lot so that the the field of
people listening to podcasts as is
thinned out a lot so as you guys alluded
to it it's tough to grab those big
numbers and have an audience but but
Carolla had a great platform to come
from he took over for Howard Stern on
CBS Joe Rogan UFC guy I'm right huge
audience
Marc Maron kind of built his up from he
well he came from that air America radio
yeah yeah but not not to say that that's
what did it for them but it it certainly
helps when you when you have a real you
know a real place to advertise your
presence and yeah I mean I think in not
to just keep blowing bill but I think
that's what makes bill specialist
because he really build it up on that
just how kind of an stand up you know
like guys like a tell in like Hedberg
really build up just being the best guys
on the road yeah like you know it's like
the cream completely rose to the top and
that's what I think you know I think
it's this hard work and just be on best
yeah yeah was it it's kind of what
podcasting can be too you know it's kind
of like if it's a good we have a good
show that hopefully people listen and
pass it along you know it's like it's
survival of the fittest absolutely I
agree with you hundred percent and I do
like you look at the guys like and it's
funny to and you mention to tell because
he hates podcasts he's one of the people
that like he cracks me up he it rarely
does them and when he does he shits on
him the whole time he does him so I I'm
invited would never ask him to do this I
would iíve asked him and it's just he's
just he won't do it who's this Dave
Attell
oh yeah he's funny yeah the way you know
I think he did are ease once and the
whole time he was on it he's like oh
you're a little microphone boy you know
and just really just kind of [ __ ] on the
whole podcast thing but it's because
he'll make me realizes I'm not writing
enough that's what he always does you're
looking in the mirror so I can tell
knows it's they could tell knows you're
not writing enough all right oh you're
wasting time when that podcast I saw
your set you know so let's talk about
somebody you think this hard about
podcasting too though is we're lucky the
courts a man of the world and he knows a
lot of great people so we got to have
you it's really hard to get people to do
podcasts it is that are like funny and
great guests I think so
I think it's I think it's harder to like
like you'll have somebody on and they'll
be on to other pocket there'll be like
this is my week I'm gonna do podcasts so
they'll you'll have them on and then two
other guys have the same guy doing the
podcast like yeah like you did you did
Corolla this week you know but we'll
take Corollas trash but but it's
interesting that you kind of see it
happen in you know it's kind of like oh
ah yeah this guy he's on this and he's
on this so I try to like one we try to
never talk about stand-up comedy no we
try not to talk about stand-up comedy
even though we have stand-up comedians
because I just find that it's like who
[ __ ] cares man if you want to talk
about don't talk about santim comedy go
watch stand-up comic yeah you know but
that's why I love talking to you is
because we talk about some of the
Farrelly Brothers stuff and the
animation and the in urine racquetball
dominance yeah and your complete insane
behavior in public places yeah you know
we it to me is just if you're ever
anywhere and you see Harlan please
approach him please go up and and and
you can you know you're very worried you
don't like to shake people's hands know
you which is very weird I'm not very
weird but it's like but you won't you
won't you know you do shake some
people's hands not often but it's it's
usually fist bump I like a fist bump
yeah but fist bumps unless they're rich
and then you'll shake their [ __ ] you
know are beat no no no I always do the
fist bump do you that you like I'll do
the fist bump and it's funny to to watch
people come up to you and you're like
and you like you see them shaking it and
you just got your fist up your eye a
buddy yeah it's like can you see the
disappointment in their eyes like oh
he's not gonna shake my hand
what is that a Canadian Howie Mandel
germ thing no it's like I have to talk
about stand up for a second but you know
III shake when you when you when you do
stand-up and when you when people
recognize you you end up shaking
thousands and thousands of hands a year
right you know ten tens of thousands
possibly you know because everyone wants
to line up after your shoulders and
shake last night I couldn't wait to get
home and wash my hands yeah
the odds of you getting a virus from a
handshake which is how most cold and flu
viruses are transmitted transferred your
odds go through the roof and I've
started to find myself getting the flu
or a cold like four or five times a year
and I'm a healthy guy and I thought this
has to be coming from something and I
realized it's probably this so since
I've been doing the fist-bumping I
hardly ever get colds or flus anymore
it's amazing well go see go up and find
Harlan give a good fist bump
yeah give me a fist bump tell them all
about everything now this weekend this
Saturday night we are gonna be in Corona
yeah and what's the name of the place
and cross it's the m15 concert hall and
Grill and it's it's a great venue it's
like a newer really clean and nice like
concert hall well traditionally they do
like big bands and stuff out there but
this weekend it's me you and Sean Tweed
Lee yeah and maybe we'll get into our
underpants again I I hope so
and we're gonna do we're gonna kill it
man we're gonna do a great show and it's
gonna be Sean's gonna hem see you're
gonna come out and kill it dude in half
an hour I'm gonna come out do like 50
minutes and then Sean's gonna come back
out at the end and Sean and I are gonna
do some improv and whose line is it type
of yeah and that's what I want to say is
you got it you got to check it out cuz
when Sean and him get together and they
do shows together they always end it
with their Improv stuff and it's really
fun to watch you know it's fun to see so
check out harland's podcast a Harlan
Highway it's on all things comedy and
and at Harlan Williams calm and in
Harlem you know go to there and you also
go there for the link and I'm gonna
tweet out the link for the tickets for
oh cool for a corona and Joe what's
going on buddy I know your head you're
heading out go an east coast next week
me and Pulver see of all we in tour Fame
I mean the band getting back together we
will be in the Hartford funnybone next
week okay and then the week after that
we're at the Syracuse funnybone okay so
check it out go to all you can go to
Joe's Twitter at Joe bartnick or Paul
Versys check out Versys
website his great podcast - yeah the
versi effect check that out and and so
so there's Saturday it's me al bill kira
soltanovich
I love I love him right Antonovich
Benson and somebody else will all be at
nerdmelt so it's right so Chelsea a PLC
why might my nerd flag I don't know
allocating stone yeah it's it is it's
the all things comedy live never seen
all the Star Wars live podcast so you
want to check that out and I'll be with
Harlan this weekend now next week you
guys I want to let you know that we're
gonna be in the studio and we're gonna
be streaming live video with a very
famous legendary drummer Kenny Aronoff
whose drum for Mellencamp Fogarty's drum
for a million people you recognize his
face and tattoos when you see ya and
we'll be streaming it live and we'll
have numbers you can call in and talk
live as well so check that out and you
guys thanks so much for in Harlan thank
you brother for haven't you bang I got a
fist bump go get some Pringles Garland
Thank You Man literally we gotta get we
had a great guest we had a really I mean
you know we did Adam Carolla yeah he did
The Tonight Show though he's coming here
yeah it's coming here for us thank you
Dumb and Dumber Something About Mary
half-baked yeah and Pringles it was i
that that still like take that blew my
mind I don't know and look at magic
that's scary I was in the writers room I
was in the writers room and this guy
this guy was like a wooden these people
in those mental stuff yeah and it was
and he knew my grandfather's he knew my
grandfather's enemies think of one
person oh no [ __ ] and he said and I said
he is Dominick and literally like I'm
gonna try and they're like all the
brothers in the writing room
the dude was a medalist like he knew all
this crazy stuff [ __ ] well he was nuts
well listen you guys thanks so much and
check out the new Olive Garden yeah I
lost Hannigan Melrose all right
corner you right on the corner I'll be
the night the salad bar yeah I'll be
handing out our breadsticks because I am
the night manager
Wednesday night Wednesday night all the
best six you can eat for free hood
this isn't sensitivity training I'm
court McGowan I'm Joe Barton thank you
guys and have a great week you guys and
have a great week you guys and have a
great week you guys